Israeli forces say they are targeting
hezbollah's military infrastructure at
times that means homes in Border
Villages officials in southern Lebanon
say up to 250 have been destroyed and
6,000 others damaged along the 120 km
Border in the past 4 months of fighting
Israel appears to be creating a new
reality it says it doesn't want its
northern border to be vulnerable as its
Southern one was when the Palestinian
group Hamas attacked in October the
Israelis want Hezbollah forces to pull
back through its attacks Israel is
trying to push their resistance
kilometers away from the border and it's
doing it by force displacement but
slowly meter by meter but it won't be
able to achieve
this the streets and villages in
southern Lebanon are empty officials say
that around 880,000 people close to the
Border have been displaced daily life
has been DED rupted but the handful of
those who stayed are
defiant they have tried Us in the past
nothing will make us leave neither
planes artillery drones or white
phosphorus we will remain steadfast
because this is our land it is Israel
who should be
afraid so far the Waring sides have
confined attacks to military targets but
nearly 30 civilians including
journalists have been
killed officials here are warning
against Israel's attempts to drag
Lebanon into a broader War they accuse
it of expanding the scope of its attacks
while threatening and promoting
proposals that are rejected such as
pushing Hezbollah north of the Lani
river which is about 25 kilm from the
border Hezbollah says Israeli threats to
expand the conflict are just rhetoric
and pressure to reach a deal but Israel
has escalated its fight against the
group and for now at least it is trying
to destroy the party's strength south of
the Lani River zenah aljazera Southern
Lebanon make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer